that's part of our job right what i
don't like
is that he pulls his weapon immediately
he would probably be the person tackled
if he did that
hi my name is ken bombase and i have
over 20 years of law enforcement
experience
i've led a company as the ceo of global
threat solutions it is a
protection firm that provides
comprehensive protection services
to executives people of high net worth
and celebrities
and today i'm going to be reviewing
movie and tv clips of bodyguard scenes
and rating them for realism
[Music]
you're never going to be distracted you
don't text you don't make calls
you're definitely not going to be
writing something down while you're
driving a client
protection agents will have what we call
like a go bag a tactical bag
a go bag and you're going to have
everything you need in there if you'll
even put some food
drinks in there you might have to sit in
that vehicle for hours right
to do your job you'd have a flashlight
you have your laptop with you
you're gonna have your phone chargers
backup battery chargers
it's something right with pens if you
have to take notes when you're when your
principal's giving you some instructions
or maybe a staff member
these are just some of the things that
you might have with you
at any time
and mighty protection agent be uh uh
test with watching the
principal's dog while they're in a
meeting or something sure it does happen
you definitely don't fire warning shots
in a situation
like this i i understand it's part of
the storyline but that's
something we don't do your mission and
this applies to
every clip that i'll talk about in any
protection operation
is to get the principal off the x we
call it the
x being the location of danger the
immediate vicinity of danger
our job is to get them out of there as
fast as we can and that's it
firefights and shootouts whether in a
military or in police
they're chaotic and confusing when i was
in the military obviously i was involved
in uh
firefights when i was in in iraq as an
army officer
i think they did a pretty good job at
depicting a shootout like that
for the circumstances he had with a
one-man detail
he did the best he could in that
situation
some training goes in on their side too
meaning the principal
so code words yes that happens it could
be maybe you see something that's um
suspicious that they don't know so you
would use a word rather than just say
hey watch out there's a thread
i would give it a seven
[Applause]
i've done a celebrity detail for a big
award show
and when my principal exited the vehicle
he decided to run
about a half a mile down a street
crowded with fans and slapping all their
hands and i had to run right alongside
of them there was no
there was no telling him not to
[Music]
they're not going to be in a room where
the celebrities actually
getting changed but rehearsing prepping
in a green room
absolutely you would you it's very
likely you would have a protection agent
in there
excuse me miss i know this isn't the
right time but i have a daughter who
wants to be a singer i was wondering a
few
many tips for her as the ceo
of a protection firm that is what i
refer to as a fireable offense
if you do not as your celebrity client
is about to head on stage
stop her in front of a group of all of
our staff and ask her for a personal
favor or personal uh opinion
that is something we do not do totally
unprofessional
waiting on an airstrike and we're
waiting and we're waiting and then my
satellite phone rings
yeah they may not be assigned to go out
into the crowd
that does not mean you're playing cards
in the back room you need to be right
backstage monitoring everything
not playing cards
that part right there i would say is
pretty realistic she exits the stage
there's a chaos obviously this is a
large venue
big concert there's venue security and
venue staff that you have no control
over there so sure that could happen
what do they do they move her quickly
and professionally out of there
you know they're human and you're human
as long as you're doing your job
um you know you could obviously support
them
to make them feel better during this
tough time i've had scenarios where
principals are emotional and upset over
something that happens they're
afraid quite frankly and and they do
show their appreciation you would just
want to guard against
um keeping up keeping boundaries done
you don't want you don't want to get too
close
in this industry so you maintain a
certain level of professionalism
i would expect him after that
interaction to to let me know about it
that it happened i'll give it a uh i'll
give it a 6.
i think the fight scene was pretty
unrealistic they're having a fistfight
in the street but then another subject
who was the driver or someone else
that's assisting and kicking the person
on the ground
could there be untrained people that
call themselves bodyguards that do that
sort of thing sure
no this is a bad neighborhood are you
worried about me
i'm fine it does happen where people can
be inebriated they can be belligerent
you have to remember this person is all
intents and purposes your boss the
principal
so you may rely on staff members that
you work closely with non-security
people who work closely with them or
even family members to intervene
you also want to protect them against
things like embarrassment there's a
famous scene where
somebody popped out and hit bill gates
in the face with a pie
that is a tragic fail for a protection
team for that to have been able to
happen
was he assassinated no but was he
embarrassed was his um
was he not happy with that scenario is
that a liability to him as a businessman
sure
of course it could happen yeah you can't
leave them they're in a situation where
they could get hurt
or they're vulnerable of course so yes
when you physically have to you would if
that's the scenario
people it's you know principals are
people too
well i've done a thorough review of both
you huh
and your corporate headquarters really
yes a comprehensive assessment on an
estate or residence
and the corporate facility of course we
would do that but what i would say is
you would not do it most likely without
the principles
knowing about it and assisting because
you wouldn't have access to everything
that you need to really do a
comprehensive security assessment
that part of it where he sort of
surprised him with it saying i've
already done it
there's only so far you can go
might you in a certain scenario use your
body to tackle or or um
or at least shield your principle sure
that could happen if there's a great
enough threat to them
would you do it in this scenario
probably not it's an unrealistic
scenario to begin with but you would
probably not do it it might be the last
time you work for them
it's a thinking person's game this is
not a brute force game
you need people with an intellect you
need people who can think on their feet
maintain calm when things get hectic
and that could be not necessarily an
immediate threat to your principle
you have developed an entire itinerary
for the day you've done advanced site
visits and in a moment's notice they
said we changed our mind now we're going
here to another state
those are the things you have to be able
to adapt and continues
seamlessly with your mission it takes a
certain type of person to be able to do
this work
you cannot panic easily you need to be
able to maintain calm at all times
do we have some people in this industry
who are 275 pounds and six foot four
sure is that the norm absolutely not you
know
you do want someone who's physically fit
who has a good appearance
that they can do this job aesthetics are
important especially for many principles
but we do not need somebody who's a
bodybuilder who's got a mixed martial
arts fighter necessarily to do this job
that's a one i don't like zeroes
you would want to know as much about
them as possible she even reviewed her
social media
for anything she might need to know
about her lifestyle or any concerns
but also it goes so much deeper than
that we have an onboarding process
really
where you're going to want to know their
blood type you're going to want to know
if they have any medical conditions or
allergies
in the modern era you can find out a lot
about people
just from open source intelligence just
by using the internet and doing open
source searches
would you stand around looking like a
security agent in the corner of the bar
watching them or in close proximity
no a lot of times what you would do is
go sit at the bar or go
sit at your own table act like you're
eating have a drink maybe a
non-alcoholic drink
and keep an eye on them while looking
what it's something we would call like
covert protection
so you don't want to be over pretty
realistic in
every aspect i'm going to give it an
eight
[Music]
executive protection agents don't have
hidden exotic weapon vaults
and that they use to choose their
weapons for the day
they definitely don't choose dual
silence pistols
and and they also don't grab them by the
trigger when they pull them out of that
vault which is something we learned day
one
in the military or in the police service
is that
they call it tf out of tg keep your
trigger finger out of your trigger guard
and he violates every one of those rules
sometimes we travel in motorcades more
than one vehicle of course
lead and follow vehicles if the threat's
high enough depending on the size of
your detail
they depart and arrive together however
they don't join the principal's vehicle
at high speeds uh
and in very close proximity if the
engine started i want an immediate
takeoff
airspace has already been cleared roger
that we
definitely do not have the authority to
clear airspace in the private protection
industry i've never heard of that happen
and sometimes clients will wait
a considerable time on the tarmac before
departure we do a lot of work in los
angeles and in new york
they will use what we call fbos those
are the private air terminals
they will use those at major airports
but oftentimes they're
fbos that we use are in smaller regional
airports
close to major airports
you probably would not roll out the blue
carpet and have a uh a ceremony on the
tarmac as you're getting them into the
aircraft it would probably be a covert
departure
nothing for mars chief almost boring
what's our motto
boring is always best you would
definitely not line up all of your
detailed vehicles like in this manner
having everybody stand there this is
something i've never seen i can
guarantee you they wouldn't have their
private security helicopter hovering
over the
over the runway too that would not be
allowed
[Music]
they mentioned get the cleanup team and
here we don't have cleanup teams for
when principals are assassinated
uh the only cleanup team you're gonna
need is is for your career because it's
probably gonna be over if something like
this happens
we have people visit every location
they're going to go days in advance
meet with points of contact plan what
route they're going to take in and out
of that building
we have to plan safe houses we have to
know the closest level 1
trauma center in case there is an
incident like this where someone gets
shot or hurt
we have to have safe houses which might
be a police station close by or
someplace we know we can bring the
principal if there's a problem
there's contingencies for everything but
i can tell you
assassinations like this are principles
extremely rare
i would say i would give it a one just
because i don't want to give anybody a
zero
in a populated place a department store
i always walk ahead of you
i don't like more than five feet between
us so if you ditch me because my back is
to you that would be too far we don't
walk in front of the principal
you don't do that because you can't see
them if you're a one-man
detail like he is in this scenario
you protocol would say usually to the
rear right just
offset not directly behind them but
offset to the rear right now they
approach a door
are you going to just step out in front
and maybe get that door for him sure you
can do that you have visual all the time
and you're staying in close proximity
might you have a principal that says
don't get the door for me i don't like
people getting doors for me yeah
i've had that too so it all depends on
the preference of them but
you're definitely not going to walk in
front of them because you know what
happens you turn around and they're gone
risk of being ungentlemanly i can't
carry bags my hands always have to be
free
people do get bags here and there are we
used
to exclusively do that and we're loading
their packages and not watching them and
jeopardizing security no we're not
do you help your principal when you're
getting him into a car
put a bag in the trunk and take that
from this is this is a customer service
based
business what is it that you look for
exactly
before he decides he's gonna walk out
and chat with her and tell her a little
bit about what he does
he'll you see he glances over to the
dressing room area that
as as far as i can see in the scene
she's the only one there he feels
comfortable
what about him it's me why is he wearing
a coat
i don't know i don't know either there's
two kind of things i'd be looking for
one of them would be someone who has an
unnatural
interest in my principle they're
watching them they seem to be in every
store they're in
that would be that would raise alarms
for me also
there could be a threat by somebody just
like in regular life any place that
that threat might not even know who your
principal is or that you're even there
but sometimes you know things happen in
public where somebody could maybe
there's fights that could break out or
maybe there's somebody who's an
emotionally disturbed person visibly you
can see
those are things you'd want to keep an
eye on we have a rigorous training
program for our agents
to conduct protection operations i would
also add that there's only so much you
can do
in training for observation skills some
people have innate
really well inherent observation skills
but
it is also a learned skill it's
something you have to put time into and
and discipline and you can learn it i
would probably give that first scene
maybe a four but the second scene i like
i think it's pretty realistic actually
so i'm gonna give that one an
eight
he's maintaining calm he's go
maintaining radio communications to make
sure he gets help
there as quickly as possible that's the
first thing to do and he's trying to
keep her calm and guide her in what to
do they have a high-powered rifle that
went through the ballistic glass but
won't go through the armor
he has to stay down she has to stay down
to try and maintain safety
would i exit that armored vehicle not
knowing exactly where the threat is out
there
to accommodate that and maybe get a
picture with my phone to try and find
them
no that part i think is unrealistic
[Music]
that other agent they make it very clear
is what we call a doa or
dead on arrival that person is not
someone who needs medical attention
you might want to climb right on top of
them to get that vehicle out of there
this is a
this is a dire situation
performance driving is being able to do
one of those j-turns which is
a fancy way for turning around very
quickly and being able to just being
able to drive
at a high rate of speed in reverse it's
not that easy so these are things that
you would train in
that's an armored vehicle they have
special training which i've been to
and my agents many of them have been to
to drive armored vehicles they're
much heavier than a regular vehicle they
handle
much differently they stop slower they
accelerate slower
so he gets off the x i like that when he
stops he has his follow vehicle with him
i like that
that's where the realism stops the
problem with law enforcement officers if
there is one using this type of work
is that it's very different law
enforcement work someone has a gun
there's a bad guy
somebody who's shooting people you go
towards them but in protection work
that's not your problem
i give it a at 8.
that's part of our job right to take a
shot for
a client a principal what i don't like
is that he pulls his weapon immediately
he spots this person that he identifies
as a threat nobody else has
he would probably be the person tackled
if he did that i could tell you when
these awards
and i've been i've done security at many
of them there's no weapons allowed
even off-duty police officers who are
now hired to do protection services at
these venues
they're not allowed to bring weapons in
nobody gets weapons and that's the idea
it's a weapons-free environment
what we do is what um heightened sense
of observation obviously because it's a
big crowd but the good news is
at those large award shows like that not
just anybody can get in there
they're vetted you know people are on on
guest list with credentials i've worked
those lines checking those credentials
for people to get in
with that being said can just like in
this scenario can somebody get
cr press credentials perhaps i mean it
doesn't take much to get him nowadays
and i've seen that
where someone with press credentials has
gotten into a green room at an event
they shouldn't have been at they weren't
a legitimate journalist
everybody probably has their own
security they don't get to bring them in
and sit at their table with them those
people
at most would be backstage waiting and
observing it's a rotation
as the celebrities come out their
security person waits and then escorts
them back out to their green room or
wherever they're going to exit
also sometimes i've been at events where
they hired one company
to do all the security for these people
so you would have though
someone assigned to specifically
escorting them back and forth all of
these people to wherever they're going
until they get to their um
to their own uh exit or security team
my firm was was hired at one point to do
a
large-scale political event with
multiple presidential candidates
and i had to provide probably 40
agents because we would have someone
assigned to each
one of those candidates the entire time
they were there
i'll give it a 6. i want to introduce
you to someone
john diggle he'll be accompanying you
from now on i don't need a
babysitter having clients that oppose
having protection services or they have
it against their will
is something that definitely happens i
don't want there to be any confusion mr
queen my ability to keep you from harm
will outweigh your comfort
do we have an agreement you don't talk
to a principal that way that he does
will you call all the shots
i like to point this out where
ultimately the client really does make
the final decisions even with the
president of the united states
got your eyes open that's what i'm here
for sir than answering patronizing
questions
they don't want you following them
around with an earpiece on and
making a very high profile that they
have a security you might sit in the
corner of the room and just observe
things
so you're always going to watch the
people in close proximity to your
principal
you're going to see if anyone has an un
natural
uh focus or a level of attention on your
principle
you're going to watch for things
anything that might be suspicious or or
seem uh like somebody could be unstable
or dangerous and anytime they interact
with someone you're going to just keep
an eye on that
you're not going to hover over there
around their back and and ready to
attack anyone at any time it's
unrealistic
this is not a high realism rating no for
multiple reasons i i would give it a uh
i'd give it a two